warning is going to be from julia rubino
who's going to tell us about
experimental entanglement of temporal
orders and
julia i should say as a postdoc at the
university of bristol
thank you
maybe i should specify that the talk i'm
giving today is about the result i
actually obtained when i was still based
in vienna so it's with a group of vienna
and also this is going to be a slight
change of topic with respect to the
previous two talks
before mine because well
i'm gonna present an experiment
and also uh it's an honestly different
topic because it's gonna be on uh on the
field of indefinite quantum causality
but i'm gonna introduce a little bit
what i entered what i mean by this and
and of course what is this research
field about
so
um
when we talk about causality and causal
relation between events
um we usually refer to the
we need to refer to the spatial distance
in between two events and the temporal
distance between the two events to
understand whether there can be a causal
relation or not between one another now
when we talk about
spatial and temporal distances we always
do this
based on an underlying sort of metric
that defines the space-time structure
for the
conditions that we are considering and
in general we do this
referring to what we know from from from
general relativity and from the fact
that we know that the presence of a
gravitational mass would
curve the space time around itself and
so basically that events closer or
farther from the gravitational mass will
then
correspond to different
space-time
coordinates
based on the the distance to the
gravitational mass
now
on the other hand if we instead think of
quantum mechanics um
we know that there are some uh peculiar
properties of this of this of this
theory as for instance so we don't
really talk about causality normally in
this in this context but we do talk
instead still about for instance spatial
coordinates and we know that one
property that we can have in quantum
mechanical systems is to see uh
systems that can be
space delocalized over two or more uh
positions they can be in quantum
superposition of two or more positions
for instance if i take a if i take a
quantum particle and i place it in a
eigenstate of say this state plus where
by plus i mean zero plus one
then it won't be in a well-defined state
of the coordinates serum one and so it
will be in a quantum superposition of
these two coordinates
uh now if we then think back of what i
was saying just a slide ago about the
the fact that the presence of a
gravitational mass would deviate the
metrics around itself one could then be
wondering what would happen in a
scenario in which i'm considering a
gravitational mass being space
delocalized over two positions and
therefore having that the matrix is uh
curved uh differently depending on which
position the particle is occupying
um so
people have been talking have been
thinking about these sorts of scenarios
a lot when even for instance thinking of
theories of quantum gravity and stuff
like this but even before that one could
just even wonder like
how can we formulate a theory with a
fluctuating causal structure which would
derive from such a scenario so this was
one of the questions that was
uh originally posed by the the field of
of indefinite causality so uh the field
of indefinite causality was basically
meant to try to answer this question
about
formulating theories in fluctuating
causal structure and being able to
perhaps observe experimentally systems
with with fluctuating causal structure
with so-called genuinely indefinite
causal structures
now in general
i'm going to be talking a lot in this
talk about genuinely indefinite causal
structures and
what do we mean by indefinite causal
structure so let's consider now some
signaling correlations and
for instance in standard quantum
mechanics a well-defined order of events
is generally assumed so if i have
even just the easy case of two events a
and then b
if i have that event a is before um
sorry
is signaling to the event b uh this
means that we mean by this that the
event b is in the light con of a whereas
if uh b is signaling to a then we
usually mean we mean that uh a is in the
light cone of b whereas if a and b are
causally independent well this can mean
for instance that they are in uh
neither of them is in the light of one
another
now
can one find correlations which are
incompatible with any underlying quasar
structure
the question basically means if we can
find situations in which even though we
have one-way signaling we have basically
quantum superpositions of walkway
signaling so not just
a one-way signaling the way i'm showing
here nor
a convex mixture of these two
um
what do i mean by that
um so in general i will call a definite
causal structure a situation like for
instance this one where i have two
parties alice and bob in two local
laboratories so they are basically
closed inside these laboratories and
they only interact with external world
through the state that they receive as
an input and then through the state that
they meet as an output but they don't do
anything any further
interactions with external work
and suppose that i send to them a target
system
and for instance suppose that i have an
additional system let's call it control
system that is just a coin a classical
coin that i flip and whenever i get say
tails then i'm going to send it to alice
first and then to bob and instead
whenever i get heads for instance i send
it to bob first and then to alice and
then at the end i will measure this
i will measure this target system
now this is what i mean by a um
a definite causa structure so it was a
structure where a acted before b or b
acted before a or any com class a
classical convex mixer between me
flipping the coin and the event
happening half of the times in one order
after the time in other order this is
still what we mean by uh definite causal
structure an indefinite because a
structure will be something that cannot
be written in this form so where
it it's not that with a classical
probability a happened before b or b
happen before a
for instance a situation in which i have
a control system which is a two-level
quantum system
in this scenario i would have that
i could do basically the same thing i
was saying in the previous slides but i
would encode at this point um sending it
to l is first as for instance zero
sending it to bob first as say one and
so if i were to place the control system
in a quantum superposition of zero and
one i would be sending it in a quantum
superposition to alice first and to bob
first and this is an instance of what we
call an indefinite causal structure and
it's what i will refer later as a
quantum switch now in this case of
course i only use the easy case of two
parties but of course everything what
i've been talking about can be
generalized to the case of more and it
has been generalized to the case of more
parties
um
now
so this was an example of an indefinite
causal structure
um
one of the goals of indefinite causality
was to demonstrate experimentally the
existence of indefinite was a structure
in nature
now
as i started my talk i was talking about
a gravitational masses and how they
deviate the metrics around themselves
now of course doing such an experiment
as i was introducing before is is quite
challenging
because we would have to detect how um
a particle that is perhaps a
nanoparticle particle of that a particle
of a reasonable size that can be placed
in a quantum superposition where to
deviate the metrics around itself
so um
those experiments were
quite challenging to perform uh however
the the possibility to perform
experiments in indefinite causality was
then opened up by uh the observation
that uh some of the features of
indefinite causality could also be
observed in a flat space time through
tabletop experiments so through for
instance uh single photons and tabletop
quantum optical experiments of course
not all the features i mean definite
causality there are some aspects that
are
particularly relevant to the to the
gravitational case and those aspects
cannot be discussed with the use of
single photons of course being them
massless
however this um observation opened up
the possibility of performing
experiments in indefinite causality with
relatively easy and manageable quantum
setups and so after this observation
quite many groups around the world have
uh performed demonstrations of first
demonstrations of indefinite causality
now the first demonstrations that were
performed of indefinite causality were
um so-called theory dependent and they
were done with use of uh so-called
causal weaknesses
for whoever of you is familiar with the
concept of entanglement weaknesses this
is basically the same concept but
applied to causal processes and so uh
basically just as much as one would be
able to define an entanglement weakness
for um the density matrix of a state
one would define a causal weakness for a
process matrix so would be able to
characterize the uh the set of um
causally non-separable causally
indefinite processes
realize that this is a closed convex set
and then derived a hyperplane that can
act as a weakness for the specific
process that one is analyzing and can
use this hermitian operator this
causal weakness to um
to demonstrate that the the setup that
one has built in the lab was an
indefinite causal structure now this was
a first
quite like let's say the most
straightforward way to prove indefinite
causality and it has been uh performed
with many different degrees of single
photons so with orbital angular momentum
with path polarization time beams and
and quite a few uh papers have come out
on on on this topic even from uh also
from our group
um
so we wanted to go
beyond this idea and try to provide a
stronger proof as a proof that would not
be uh devised um sorry theory dependent
so it would not um
require on the knowledge of the how we
can write a process matrix and derive
the causal weakness
now
we know that this should be possible in
principle because
orisk of kostenbruchner proposed some
device independent ways of certifying
indefinite causality via some so-called
causal inequalities for whoever review
isn't familiar with this one can imagine
them as some sort of um
analogous of the bell inequalities but
for the case of of causality so a
technique that would allow you where you
to violate those inequalities
would allow you to demonstrate that
the process that you have
observed
was a
causally uh non-separable process an
indefinite causal process in a
device-independent planner by violating
these inequalities
now
um
unfortunately we haven't yet even though
according to their predictions it seems
that quantum mechanics allows for
existence of processing violating causal
inequalities we haven't yet found uh
physical processes that can actually
performed in a lab and could be able to
violate kuznet inequalities so for
instance the quantum switch that was
just in the previous slide uh would is
unable to violate causal inequalities
so even though it it it can be shown as
cousin inseparable
with a with a causal weakness
um so um
so the question was okay if
we cannot
uh violate i mean at least we don't know
yet how to violate causal inequalities
um in
in an experiment can we still do
something that is stronger than
proving a causal witness so which is as
much as possible uh theory independent
um to prove indefinite causality even
though this is not as strong as
violating causal inequalities which
would be even device independent
um
and
so this was basically the the goal of of
this um
of this of this uh of this experiment
i'm trying to answer the question of if
it is at all possible to prove the
existence of indefinite causality in a
manner that applies to a broader cross
of theories uh than just a quantum
theory
uh so this brings me now to the to the
actual talks now i i did more um kind of
an overview of the research field
because i thought probably um some of
you might not be extremely familiar with
with what i was about to talk about so
this was more like the research field
itself and now i'm gonna enter instead
in the in the result that i was meant to
present today which is this um
bell's theorem for temporal orders and
it's uh violation via an experiment uh a
quantum optical experiment so i'm going
to start by introducing the nugo theorem
for temporal orders uh which was um by
the way it was originally introduced by
magdalena and collaborators in a theory
paper and then we adapted it for the
case of this
quantum optical experiment um then i'm
going to present the experimental
realization that we perform to
calculate this uh to violate this this
theorem and perform this proof and then
i'm going to give some outlook and
perspectives
so the the nogo theorem
um
so
consider just omega to be a state of a
composite system of the control system
this control system was
just this for instance the coin that i
was using before
that was in a classical case or the
two-level system that would decide the
order between the two and the target
system that instead was the one on which
alice and bob were performing their
operations now we will consider this to
be a composite system of of two because
of course we want to uh adapt some uh
bell test to this case and so uh of
course we need two parties so we will
have to use two quantum switches in a
configuration that i will show you now
it's what we call an entangled quantum
switch
um
so the novel theorem is say is basically
what follows we have these three
assumptions
the first says that the initial joint
state of the target system is a bell
local so it it does not violate a bell
inequality
uh by itself then the second uh
assumption is that the laboratory
operation so what alice and bob perform
on this target system
are preserve the locality of the state
of the target system so they are
non-entangling operations uh between the
two targets and the the control and the
target basically
and so when they apply to a bell local
state they
maintain a bit local state and then the
third assumption is that the order of
these local operations that elizabeth
perform is
is well defined
so it is not an indefinite causal
structure if all the three assumptions
are verified
then on
no state set of transformation a
measurement which which obeys
assumptions one two three
is able to perf to violate a bell
inequalities performed at the output of
the two switches
so if now i perform this experiment and
i observe a violation of a bell
inequality this shows me that one of the
three assumptions at least one of the
three assumptions if not more
has to be uh wrong
now uh so this is what i was talking
about before when i was saying okay i'm
gonna introduce to you the the the
entangled quantum switch which is a
generalization of what i was talking
about before when i introduced just the
two parties elise and bob as i said
before uh because i want to do a belt
test i need two switches because of
course
the two outputs i will want to do um
about tests so i will need at least a
two-part system so i will have two
alice's and two bobs
and just as in the case before before i
was saying oh if my control state is in
the state zero then i'm gonna send it to
ellis first and then to bob in this case
i will have that the control state will
be 0 0 and i will send it to the two
alice's first and then the two bobs
and instead
when it's in the state 1 1
i will send it to the two bobs first and
then the two alice's and then in the
output
um this is when this is the thread of
the control system and this is the same
the target system
uh
and then at the output as i was saying
before i will have two parties that will
perform two uh bell tests i mean a bull
test together uh that they will measure
correlations uh at the outputs
now
um before entering in the in the actual
result that we obtained i want to just
outline to you uh the idea behind this
and how how it's gonna work
now
as it turns out it is easier to explain
you the idea uh by using quantum
mechanics so
using cat and so on and then the the
experimental proofs that i will actually
perform would be also outside quantum
mechanics and in more in a broader class
of generalized probabilistic theories
but at least now for explaining how the
process works i'm going to use quantum
mechanics
so the the initial state of of the
system uh will be
in a
separable state for the target
i'll prepare it this way because so this
is just outlining like what we are going
to do in this experiment so i'm going to
prepare a state that is uh separable in
the target so that i can then perform
the test to uh to verify the
separability over this and i will
prepare an entangled state of the
control system so something like like
this where zero zero is alice and then
bob and one one is bob and the dennis
um
then
again depending on the state of the
control system either at least it's
gonna act first or bob is gonna act
first so uh when the state is uh zero
alice will act first for switch one
and also for switch two alias will hack
when first and then bob
instead for when the control system is
in the state one then bob will act first
and then alice in both switches
um
then i will perform here some
projections of the the control system in
plus minus basically i'm gonna close the
interferometer to erase the the which
path information coming from um the two
the two paths so i'm going to project on
plus minus and observe then uh perform
this this belt test on the projected
state on the control system plus minus
and uh so this is basically what's what
i get from my projection
and then i perform two um
kind of
smart choices of what elise and bob
should be performing
so of course i want to be able to
tell something about their mutual order
so i don't want to choose operations
that for instance would commute because
then there would be no point in talking
about the order between one another so i
want to choose some operations for alice
and bob that are such that if alice acts
first or or bob acts first they're gonna
on the same system on the same state
they're gonna give rise to two
orthogonal states
so of course there is not a unique
choice for this but one possible choice
is that the two alices perform sigma z
and the two bobs perform identity plus i
sigma x over square root of two
and this is the choice that we adopted
for uh the
for the experiment i will present later
and if you perform this choice
they perform those operations on
this uh
state 0 of the
of the target system and i'm going to
obtain this
l and r which are
left-handed and right-handed uh state
for instance of polarization but in
general can be any sort of superposition
zero plus i one and zero minus i one
and so because this is a bell state
in principle i should be able to use it
to then violate a bell inequality in the
outputs
so this is basically how the idea works
how we
thought we can
construct this this experiment to um
observe a violation uh through an
entangled quantum switch
uh now of course the uh
the overall idea as you probably have
understood by now is that this is
basically an entanglement transfer
i'm starting with a separable state in
the target and an entangled state in the
control but the control controls the
order in which the operations are
performed over the target so the
entanglement is transferred from the
state of the control
to the way in which operations are
performed to the parties as the order
sorry and then to the the target systems
so uh it was an entanglement transfer
that went from the control to the target
passing through the order of the
operation of of the gates and this is
basically uh the the the understanding
behind this that you can uh have within
within quantum mechanics uh now i'm
going to present the the result of the
experiments of course that's kind of
invalidated on the theorem and then
analyze each of the assumptions beyond
quantum mechanics also
so
this
just remind you what's the nugget
theorem so we have three assumptions and
then we have the the bell theorem now
i'm gonna start just so that you are
prepared for what is coming after i'm
gonna start with the belt here and
violation
so this will tell me because i will
observe a violation this will tell me
that at least one of the three
assumptions must be must be wrong if not
more and then i'm gonna start analyzing
one assumption at a time
uh both within quantum mechanics and uh
in more in a probabilistic theories
um
so this is the setup that we use to
perform this experiment so it's a is a
bulk optics uh quantum optical setup uh
where we use uh photon uh photon
entangled um pairs of of photons which
were entangled in the state of the
of the sort of the path and separable in
the state of the polarization
um then the
two were sorry
one photon was injected in one switch
and the other photon was injected in the
other switch
and if they were
in a superposition of these two states
and these two states so it would either
inject it from here or from here and say
same from the other
uh so if it was injected from here for
instance then here this would be the
first operation say alice and this was
bob
so we would perform it we would it would
go through alice first and then bob and
then on a phylum splitter which was
doing the projection on uh
rl
sorry unknown plus minus otherwise it
would be injected from here and so it
would go through bob first and then
alice and then on the final beam
splitter which was projecting the
control system on plus minus
and the operations of alice and bob were
performed through some um some wave
plates that are some quartz crystals of
a specific thickness so that
they can they are basically able to
delay uh one of the two components of
the polarization horizontal over
vertical uh to uh change to be able to
perform any generalized unitary
basically that one would need to perform
and then the measurements at the output
were done also with some wavelets and
then with the polarizing beam splitter
now a beam splitter in general is like
is is a is a cube of a glass material
where uh basically a cat is performed
on the on the diagonal so that it is put
one can put like a glue such that one
can choose the splitting ratio between
in the input light so that one can be
there for instance a so-called 50 50
beam splitter where light is split
equally in the two parts and can also be
used to perform equal superposition
between the two ports and instead
polarizing beam splitter are those are
the same concept but
they split instead according to the
polarization of the
system um so
as i was saying before i'm going to
start from doing the test of the of the
bell theorem so we perform the bell test
and we observe the violation of 2.55
plus minus 0.08
so as you can see here by almost seven
eight standard deviations we uh
observed that we we were in fact
violating the bell theorem so uh
at least one of the three assumptions uh
was was wrong we did also additional
tests within quantum theory and we
checked that in fact what we were
observing at the output was indeed r r
minus l l
um
and so this told us that
one of the three assumptions has to be
wrong if no more so now i'm gonna start
to look into each of the three
assumptions to try to understand which
one could be wrong
um
yes
so let's start from assumption one
now assumption one uh you may or may not
remember was the one about the target
system being by local states so the
target systems were uh
on a separable state and they could not
be used to violate a bell inequalities
uh by by themselves as they were
injected in this entangled quantum
switch
um
so we uh we performed about tests on the
sorry we we performed first the
characterization within quantum
mechanics of the input system and we
checked that we were in fact injecting
hh whereby h i mean horizontal uh
polarization of light and yeah we had a
fidelity with a state of 0.935
and the concurrence of 0.001 so we did
we did in fact detect no not inten not
any entanglement in the
in the input target states
and uh now this was within quantum
mechanics what i just said in the
previous slide we also of course wanted
to do a test beyond quantum mechanics in
more generalized probabilities in
general probabilistic theories and so
what we used to check that the input
states were
separable
was the very concept the very definition
of separability so um the probabilities
for measurement outcomes as measurement
on the state of the target system s1 and
s2
will be separable if they can be written
in this form where uh o1 and o2 are the
outcome of the measurement at the end
and uh and these are the measurement
setting and the in this state basically
and
so here this is the joint probability
whereas this is the product of the two
marginalized probabilities and it's a
very
way to basically define the probability
so we just checked that the uh the
product of the two marginal
probabilities was was equal to the the
joint probability distribution
and this was the case so as you can see
here this is the uh this is the the list
of the joint probabilities and these are
these are the product of the marginal
probabilities and we compared the two um
the two set of outcomes uh there are no
errors in this uh in this um table but
the experimental error was uh associated
to each of them was 0.01
and the distance between these two set
of probabilities was 0.06 plus minus 2.7
to the 10 to the minus 2. so
uh compatibly with experimental error
the two set of probabilities were in
fact
compatible
so this was basically the way to prove
beyond quantum mechanics that
the assumption one
is is verified within our experimental
errors
quantum because we've only performed
tests in in basically
any anything that is beyond quantum
mechanics but with the same size as uh
quantum mechanics basically
also within quantum mechanics you could
imagine that there is an extra degree of
freedom which is quantum and in which
you have entanglement right so somehow
but not yeah but not on if i
i mean there were other degrees of
freedom that were quantum but the the
all what i was wondering was if the
degree of freedom in which like of the
target system was not entangled so there
are definitely other degrees of freedom
that are in tank that that might uh
contain entanglement but not the ones
that i was investigating this very case
of the of the target system
but yeah it's definitely ball indeed uh
we we basically performed this
experiment like not for all gpts like
that's what we kind of stated very
carefully of course in our paper uh it
does not involve any sort of gpts and
it's not pos quantum and it's definitely
it's just for 3d books basically
uh questions oh sorry so you said that
the assumption one is verified i'm a
little bit concerned about that does
that mean that
it's just the testable implications that
you cannot reject based on the data
right it's still possible that the
assumption be violated but you don't
have enough power to reject is that
how i can understand sorry i didn't
understand the question i'm wondering if
suppose that the the verse inequality
hold
does that imply that the set of three
assumptions holds yes i mean so this is
the normal theorem so the number theorem
tells that
if uh all the three assumptions hold
then i will not observe a violation of a
bell inequality at the end right so if i
were to not observe any violation of the
inequalities then i wouldn't be
wondering which of the assumptions is
wrong because there is no no problem
with the assumptions right so because i
observed the violation
then i started wondering okay which of
the assumptions
yes but it's still possible that you
don't observe a violation but then the
assumptions failed and you cannot
dictate that right using the data uh
well
we we proved that uh so in our paper we
proved that i mean actually not in our
people in magdalene paper they proved
that
this set of assumptions is uh is enough
to kind of
uh prove that the
that should
if if a a violation of a bell inequality
were to be detected would be linked then
to one would be able to be reconducted
to one of the of the assumptions
basically but i guess the point is like
it's you're testing a null hypothesis
so
if you don't reject it that doesn't mean
it's not true
it just might mean you didn't have
enough data to reject it so i think
that's what desiree's point is uh
you mean for instance for assumption for
one of the assumptions so you're saying
you know i mean i i can if in fact for
instance for for this assumption i'm not
rejecting it for
quantum theories for instance so of
course i'm not be able to make a
statement that is fully theory
independent this is not what i am uh
able to achieve i cannot make a
statement that is fully independent of
any theory that i could be uh
considering even beyond this 3d bolts
but it is it does apply for 3d ball so
whatever theory has a three-dimensional
size as quantum mechanics and doesn't
have to be necessarily quantum mechanics
then for that it would hold but yeah it
i'm not
able to perform any statement of
anything that is beyond this three
dimension
and then
i think this is what you're asking right
i mean supposedly violator inequality
doesn't mean that the exception one of
these is sorry that the decisions hold
and no the answer is no right i mean
uh you have a quantum system actually
that can come short on locality but
because of the experiment that you're
doing is not showing on locality so
still the assumptions do not hold but
you're not detecting about violation i
think this is what we are asking
so
so if all the three assumptions are
correct it's not an initial if but if
all the three assumptions are correct
then i cannot observe a violation so if
i observe a violation then i can go the
other way around
yeah yeah sorry
yeah yeah yeah sorry so okay
yes
it's a very basic question because i'm
again not quite fond
you started out with quantum gravity
and in the case of quantum gravity i
could imagine we don't really have a
theory
but there are literally two events
called an alpha and beta
embedded in an indefinite metric
which is a superposition such that
in one term of the superposition alpha
precedes beta and the other beta
if i'm following this correctly
that's you what what you're now doing is
you're sending a single particle either
first to alice and then to bob refers to
bob and then to alice but there is no
division so really there are four events
right there's as it were alice early
alice late bob early bob late and if
alice and bob were quickly switching
their experimental apparatuses you'd get
entirely different results because
they'd actually be measuring differently
yes
so
that's not similar to the case where i
couldn't do that in the quantum in the
gravity case right because they're just
two events but now we really have four
events so when you talk about
indefinite causal order it's not in the
sense of quantum gravity is that right i
agree yes so uh there are some just in
case you are interested there are some
papers that talk exactly about this uh
there is a paper by marco virginovic
which was published in quantum
in 2021 i think so a year ago it is
exactly about this and also this topic
has been discussed a lot uh so we also
have like for instance a paragraph where
we talk about this idea uh in our paper
and the idea is that of course um if
alice and bob uh alice and bob can tell
apart a so-called gravitational quantum
switch so the case in which you have
this gravitational mass that i was
talking a bit about at the beginning
with a quantum optical setup so elise
and bob can definitely attend them apart
because they would see
the quantum particle that experiences
that who cannot tell them apart but
definitely they could so we are not i'm
i'm definitely not stating and and
that's what i was specified at the
beginning of my talk that this is a
one-to-one uh situation but for the for
the from the perspective of the quantum
particle uh it is
okay i should continue otherwise i'm all
finished um so now uh so i wanted to
test an assumption uh assumption two so
i'm just to
go back to what i was talking about
before in my previous uh like uh
in my previous slides i was talking
about the amplification of assumption
one uh but now so now i verified that
assumption one holds um also uh beyond
the quantum mechanics still within 3d
bolts and now i'm moving to assumption
two assumption two was telling me that
alice and bob perform operations that
are non-entangling operations on the two
target systems and on the controlling
target system
now um
so
this is a little bit trickier to verify
because as it turns out a quantum switch
does perform a coupling between a
control and a target system so uh
proving that they don't perform
entangling operations uh
it's
it's not possible within a quantum
switch because actually
because i'm injecting an entangled
control system they end up performing a
um
within a quantum switch they end up
performing entangling operations so what
we wanted to show was just that
only the operation of alice or only the
operation of bob where non-entangling
operations so um so because of this we
kind of separated the two cases in which
assumption basically assumption three is
right or wrong so because we said okay
assumption one is right so there are
only two assumptions left assumption two
or assumption three either one of the
two is wrong or both
so let's now suppose that assumption
three is right so that the order between
the parties is well defined
and let's analyze assumption 2 alone
so in this scenario i'm not going to
consider the case of the quantum switch
but i'm only considering
basically having only alice
or only bob performing their operations
and and the other one is just gonna do
an identity channel and so what i did
was then i so
i performed uh a test to prove just this
and this would be enough already to make
a statement about assumption three
because if i have uh if i
um
prove for instance that whenever
assumption three is verified so is
assumption two then
this like assumption two through then
assumption three through then assumption
uh
two through would imply also that not
two is not three
so because of that
basically we what we performed was a
test where we consider assumption three
to be correct so the order between the
parties is well defined and we only
performed operations on alice and on bob
alone
and uh we perform basically kind the
same idea as before so perform tests uh
on the
joint probability and marginalized
probability the products of the two and
we saw that the two set of probabilities
were compatible um
so the the distance between the the root
square
root mean square distance between the
two probabilities was 0.02 plus minus
0.03
and so that again within experimental
error the uh assumption 2 would be
verified so this tells us that if
assumption two sorry
um if assumption two was verified then
assumption three would be verified as
well and so there is no solution for uh
that would work because uh
this would mean that all three
assumptions are correct so i wouldn't
have been able to observe a violation of
inequality because i observed the
violation of a bell inequality at least
one of the assumptions was
wrong and so this solution is to reject
the solution in which 3 is right and
therefore 2 is right so
we won't make any statement basically as
to whether 2 is right or wrong but this
tells us that assumption 3 has to be
right because assumption 3 wrong
i'm sorry assumption 3 has to be wrong
because the center and three right would
mean to write
so
uh we performed also some
additional tests adding basically some
error some noise in the system and this
was the case of insertion of noise on
the control system so we were basically
degrading the level of entanglement and
we were observing that the
uh basically we were observing uh
less and less and less of a violation of
a ball inequality until basically we
wouldn't violate anymore so of course
this can be explained in terms of the
fact that the integument transfer is not
occurring anymore because there's no
entanglement to transfer at all
and also
another sanity check on the insertion of
noise on the um
on the
we did the bell with the control qubits
in input and with the target qubits in
in output inserting noise in the in the
two in the two switches basically
and and yeah again same thing we
observed that the more noise we were
inserting the the less we were able to
violate bell inequality and so we were
not performing we were not uh be able to
perform this entanglement transfer
anymore
and the nogo theorem was no longer
violated so with this i reached the
conclusion of what i wanted to talk
today so in just to wrap up what i
talked about in this talk was uh i
performed uh the first
uh theory independent test of ballen
equality still within a smaller class of
a general probabilistic theory so not
beyond 3d ball
but
also we perform this demonstration by
introducing the concept of entangled
quantum switch and
well next well
there is still a lot to to do so it even
depends on whether the question is from
a theoretical perspective or from an
experimental perspective still within
indefinite causality uh i would say that
from an experimental perspective
uh definitely the next challenge is
scaling up the number of parties in fact
so far
quantum switches were only performed
with uh basically two parties or only a
restrictive version of a four-part
switch was performed with four parties
but not all the four factorial
permutations only only four permutations
so a full quantum switch even with three
parties has never been performed there
are a lot of experimental challenges
that of course if you're interested i
can tell you but that's the reason why
it's still an
open for like ongoing work and otherwise
even the realization of something that
is not a quantum switch so
so far everything what was realized was
either a quantum switch
or a sort of simplified version of a
quantum switch this this
four part tight quantum switch with uh
just uh four permutations so
that have been proposed some processes
that are actually beyond the quantum
switch and then can still be performed
uh in in the lab so
uh this is basically another very
interesting uh route because the quantum
switch has a whole a bunch of
limitations uh
which will if you're interested i can
tell you uh but so it would be very
interesting to then go beyond the the
quantum switch and from a theoretical
perspective i think one of the most
interesting questions is still whether
or not uh there are physical processes
that can violate causal inequalities so
there have been first results that show
that it definitely cannot be violated
with with
uh quantum control systems so like a
system like the quantum switch that
presented before
but there is still ongoing studies as to
whether or not they can actually
violate it with physical processes so
even in long theorem showing that this
cannot be achieved would be interesting
but still people are kind of working
towards either of the two directions
and with this i'd like to thank you for
your attention
very interesting thank you very much
does anyone have any questions for julio
so this is a basic question sort of
about um the definition of indefinite
causal order so
uh
in a
classical statistical setting
we could have
some variables and a
an observed probability distribution
over those variables
that is not compatible with a directed
acyclic graph
and that arises
like in practice i can't think of an
example off the top of my head but it
arises um and so people would call that
a cyclic causal model um and the point
that i want to make is that um we would
not we we don't generally consider those
things to represent exotic physics
and i i would say the reason why
uh is because
um we have a sense that the sicklicity
uh
is a is a consequence only of our choice
of of the variables it's a consequence
of our coarse-grained description um of
what in reality if we were to look
really deeply could be described in
definite causal orders in terms of
classical mechanics or whatever um
and so first of all i'm just wondering
uh in talking about indefinite causal or
they cannot be written as directed
across the clock by cyclographs
right right and so right and and so i'm
wondering how do you uh
uh
when you talk about indefinite causal
order um how do you distinguish
between this
this accidental kind of indefiniteness
which is a consequence of your choice of
coarse-grained description
and true indefiniteness at the level of
fundamental physics
uh
so for us
basically
everything what can be written as uh
a well-defined causal order so where the
parties happen like one after another in
a well-defined order or any convex
mixture of those
is uh is a causally
definite process
and so because of this we we
directly the cyclic graphs cannot be
used to uh
write tied to this
describe uh
indefinite causal processes and the way
we use to actually describe indefinite
causal processes is the so-called
process matrix formalism
uh which instead allow to include this
sort of this sort of of processes so the
way to distinguish between the two is
basically uh
the techniques i was saying
until now like for instance if you were
to perform a causal weakness or when
they were directed their cyclograph you
would see that
it it shows that it is that
a definite causal order so
right right but my point is just that in
a classical setting
we can get things
that do not have definite causal order
and we and
for instance
well so i i mean any any situation that
uh
that cannot be um explained by a by a
dag i mean like in causal modeling
people would do this
sure sure okay that's it yeah good point
so supply and demand uh we're gonna have
um we're gonna have arrows in both
directions but it is a convex mixture of
the two because it's a classical system
as you can see no it's not a convex mix
it's not a convex not necessarily a
convex mixture um it's it it's not it's
not that um
my my just my point is that the
indefiniteness the apparent
indefiniteness can arise because of the
way that we because of our choice of
course grain description and i'll i'll
pass the microphone up but that's just
so this is also very basic but basically
in response to that question
there are other time stamps is it
reasonable to think there are time
stamps attached to all of the variables
you're describing does that rule that
out
i mean
all of the variables i'm describing you
mean the measurement choices of so the
variables here are the measurement
choices the input so the choice of input
and then the measurement choices of
values and bob
uh because everything else is the
outcome of the measurements and those
are not linked to the
to the causal process so maybe i should
have actually specified this i didn't i
didn't enter in the details of that
because i wanted to perform at a tiering
independent demonstration so i didn't
enter in the details of the actual
theory of because of processes but the
idea is that uh in a quantum switch
um the the actual process is not
including what alice does what bob does
the input the choice of the input and
the choice of the measurement at the end
they can be replaced with black boxes
and the actual process is just the way
in which the information is transmitted
between the parties so the the what we
call the the the the process matrix is
just envisioning basically the uh the
the arrows that i was showing you before
and not really the
like
the
in this
uh
when i had this a
and b
and i was going through a
and then b or b
and then hey
this
are these will be replaced by black
boxes
and they are not part of microsoft
process
nor is the choice of input
nor is the choice of output but my
so-called w my my process matrix is only
what is inside this box and so it does
not include these variables
then i use the variables to perform for
instance tests to perform a causal
weakness and so on but they're not part
of the actual causal process
okay we're running rather over time so
um any other questions i guess you
couldn't ask
yourself but let's thank all three
speakers in this session
let's start again at half one so